so let's revisit a scenario that we've
seen in several videos especially the
last video where we tried to find this
neutral frame of reference
let's say we're in spaceship a we are in
an inertial frame of reference and let's
say right at time equal zero in our
frame of reference spaceship B is
exactly where we are
but it's traveling in the positive
x-direction at eight ten to the speed of
light we've already seen that we can
overlay the space-time diagrams for each
of these frames of reference if we make
this if we do our axes our you know the
X is one direction of space-time that we
associate with the X direction of space
and then the CT this vertical axis this
is another direction of space-time that
we perceive as the passage of time well
you can you can then overlay B's frame
of reference and you kind of have these
tilt these these skewed these skewed
axes and you could look at a change in
time so for example if you were to
compare the event right when B passes us
up to let's say some amount of time
later some amount of so let's say this
this right over there is a change in CT
in our frame of reference these two
events are happening at the exact same
place they're just separated in our
frame of reference we would perceive
them as being separated by time but if
you want to say well how much time seems
to separate these events in B's frame of
reference well then you would want to go
parallel to the X prime axis reviewing
B's frame of reference as a prime frame
of reference and see where we intersect
the CT prime the CT prime axis so this
is our change in CT while this is our
change in CT this looks like our change
in CT prime and it looks longer but we
have to remember that we haven't scaled
these things and actually the scales
change depending on the relative the
relative velocities but we can actually
verify algebraically that our change in
CT prime is going to be larger than our
change in CT and we just have to look at
the Lorentz transformations to realize
that so our change in CT prime is going
to be equal to the Lorentz factor times
our change in CT
- beta times our change in X we've seen
that multiple times before well our
change in X our change in X is zero it
looks stationary in our frame of
reference so that term is zero so our
change in CT prime is going to be equal
to the Lorentz factor times I have to
use parentheses anymore times our change
in CT and our Lorentz factor is going to
be greater than one I can actually
calculate that let's do it so the
Lorentz factor the Lorentz factor here
so gamma is going to be equal to one
over the square root of 1 minus well be
the B's relative velocity so 0.8 C over
the speed of light squared well what is
this going to simplify to the C's cancel
out 0.8 squared is 0.6 for one - that is
0.36 this is going to be and then you
take the square root of that it's going
to be 1 over 0.6 which is equal to 1
over 6/10 which is the same thing as 10
over 6 which is equal to the same thing
as 5 over 3 5/3 which is equal to 1 and
2/3 so you can see our change in CT
prime is going to be 1 and 2/3 times the
change in CT now you might want to just
say well does this do these two look
like 1 and 2/3 and it might look at a
little bit like that the way I've drawn
it but you can't just look at it purely
on you can't just take a ruler for this
length and a ruler for this length
because the scales are different and I
haven't marked off the scales with this
at least helps us visualize but let's
think of let's think about let's take a
round let's imagine the change in CT
prime between right where the spaceships
pass by and a little bit later now I'll
do this in a different color because
this is actually a different event in
space-time then the one that we were
focusing on right now and we're going to
be viewing it from B's frame of
reference so that's our change in CT
prime but what is it going to be our
change in CT well to think about it we
could go parallel to the x axis the x
axis right over there so you go parallel
parallel to the x axis and you get right
over
there and so our change in CT looks like
it's more and once again we can
algebraically verify it by really doing
the same thing our change in CT is going
to be equal to gamma times our change in
CT prime minus beta times Delta X prime
and if you were to actually if we
actually did have a change in X prime
here the beta the velocity has a
different direction so it'd be the
negative but our change in X prime from
B's point of view these two events are
happening in the same place so our
change in X prime is zero so you have
change in CT is equal to gamma times
change let's again I don't need my
parentheses times change in CT prime
it's going to be the same gamma because
remember we're taking V over C and so
whether it's either V or negative V when
you square it it gets the same value so
once again gamma is going to be one in
two thirds so it's going to be one and
two thirds so it seems a little bit
strange you know I have some passage of
time in my frame of reference where it
looks you know something that looks
stationary two events that look like
they're happening in the same place but
one after another it looks like their
change in time it takes longer for those
two events to happen in the CT prime for
in the in the moving frame of reference
but and then if we have some event
happen with that look stationary and B's
frame of reference and they're separated
by change in CT prime it looks like the
change in CT between those two events is
even larger so it looks like this
somewhat bizarre phenomenon and to help
us reconcile these and to visualize a
little bit better actually even to to be
able to put CT and CT prime on on us on
the same scale we can look for this
neutral frame of reference which we did
in the in and actually the last video I
made I don't know if it's the last video
you've seen or we could say look if a
and B are traveling with a relative
velocity of 0.8 times the speed of light
relative to each other B is traveling
0.8 C in the positive x-direction
relative to a stationary a or a is
traveling 0.8 C in the negative
x-direction relative to a stationary B
you can find a frame of reference where
a and B were in that frame of
reference to a stationary observer in
that frame of reference a and B are both
traveling outwards at half the speed of
light and we figured that out when we
did those videos on a neutral frame of
reference and what's neat about that is
if when you if you make with what looks
like a Minkowski space-time diagram in
that neutral frame of reference then the
C T and C T prime a and B's frame of
reference is get equally skewed to the
you know if you think about the time
axis to the left on the right and since
they're equally skewed the time-dilation
relative to this rest frame is the
scaling is going to be the same so you
could put both of these on both of these
on the same scale and you can see that
this this this neutral frame of
reference the C T prime prime frame of
reference I drew them over here that if
you look at either of a or B's frame of
reference they're going to be in between
a and B frame of reference but here it's
the neutral one it's the one where we're
drawing the time and or we're drawing
the two axes being perpendicular to each
other and now if you look at these two
events so if you look at this first
event where you have our delta CT so you
look at this first event where you have
a delta in CT between right when the
spaceships pass and right over there you
see that if you were to look at that if
you look at the CT prime coordinate for
that event well you go parallel to the X
prime axis you get right over there so
this is that is your change in CT prime
and likewise if you have that other
event that I drew in that blue green
color right over here and this is your
change in CT prime this is your change
in CT prime well then if you think of it
from a z-- frame of reference well we
just followed the x axis not the X prime
we go parallel to it we end up right
over there
now what's really interesting about this
what's really interesting about this is
the is from a z-- frame of reference the
yellow event happens before the blue
event but in B's frame of reference the
blue event happens before the yellow
event so really really really
fascinating things going on but I really
like about this diagram is that is that
a and B's frame of reference are going
to have the same
same scale since they're both equally
skewed to the left and the right if we
think about the time axis and this type
of diagram is called a lodal diagram
lodal lodal diagram which is really a
variation of a Minkowski diagram but it
lets us really appreciate the symmetry
between these frames of reference